[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY WEIR: My whole
approach to writing
is just I want to
write science fiction
and I want it to be
scientifically accurate.
So that's the kind of
playground that I live in.
And then for "The
Martian," both stories
started out as
just me envisioning
something cool
and science-y that
could happen in the future.
So for "The Martian," I was
thinking of a manned mission
to Mars.
How do you get people there?
How do you get them back?
How do you make sure they
don't die if something breaks?
What are your backup systems?
What are your backups
to your backups?
And the increasingly
desperate things
you would have to do to stay
alive if enough stuff broke,
I thought, like, oh, this could
make an interesting story.
And so that's kind of the
impetus of "The Martian."
For "Artemis," I
was thinking of,
like, what is humanity's
first city that's not on Earth
going to be like?
And so the first question I had
to think of was, like, well,
where would it be?
Would it be in low Earth orbit?
Would it be on the moon?
Would it be on Mars?
Those are really the only
three logical candidates
for the first non-Earth city.
And I decided the moon was best.
A low Earth orbit, every
gram of the city's mass
would have to be put up there.
Whereas on the moon,
there's local resources
you can make use of.
You can smelt the
aluminum that present.
There's huge amounts of oxygen
trapped in the oxides there.
And so I was like, oh, OK.
And Mars is just
too damn far away.
Like if you were standing
on a football field--
whatever your definition of
football is, but either way
you want to do it.
If you're standing
on a football field,
if Mars were at the
other goal, the moon
would be 4 inches
in front of you.
Yeah.
That's 10 centimeters.
[LAUGHTER]
So yeah, that just
gives you an idea
of the scale of the distance.
And so the moon is a much
better place to build it.
Then the next thing I was
thinking of, it's like,
OK, well, why would
you build a city?
Every city that exists
exists for a reason,
and it's always an
economic reason.
People don't go off and
build a city somewhere
because it'd be
awesome, they do it
because there's a living
to be made doing something.
Either it's a logging
town, a railroad depot,
it's on a major river so
that, you know, whatever.
And so I decided, I've always
hated the sci-fi excuses that
are given for lunar cities.
It's like, well, we're
there to mine the moon.
I'm like, send robots.
You know, robots?
First off, they're
a lot hardier.
Humans are soft and squishy
and they die easily,
and people care when humans die.
People aren't that worried
about when your robot dies.
And same thing.
It's like, oh, there's
overpopulation on Earth.
Then colonize the seafloor.
It's a lot closer and easier
to colonize than the moon.
You know?
And it's like, oh, well,
persecution on Earth.
These people fled persecution.
OK, first off, if you can
afford to move to the moon,
you're not the persecuted class.
[LAUGHTER]
And second off, even if
somehow that is true,
then your persecutors can
sure as hell come after you.
So I decided, tourism.
The answer is tourism.
So it came together
into this, OK, it's
a small tourist economy.
And I based it off--
I know I'm going way off
where your question was, but--
JASON GESSNER: No, that's great.
ANDY WEIR: --hey,
you know, I ramble.
Tourism.
So I based "Artemis" off
of real-world tourism-based
cities.
Like single-source economies
like islands in the Caribbean
or out in the Pacific
that are all--
that their only source
of income is tourism.
All they have going for
them, in terms of economics,
is the natural
beauty that they have
and the fact that people
want to come and see it.
And the way-- and
those always end up
being a bunch of high-end,
wealthy, kind of like hotels,
casinos, entertainment things,
and then the poor people who
live there.
And this is not a hashtag
#OccupyMoon kind of message
that I'm making.
I'm just saying that that's how
those economies always show up.
And so it's really neat because
you just think about one thing,
and it leads to the next thing,
which leads to the next thing.
So then I had "Artemis" and I'm
like, OK, that's a neat idea.
It seems like there'd be
a lot of different stories
that could take place there,
especially since it's too far
away from Earth to
really be-- to really
have any laws enforced on it.
So it's the old West, as well.
And so that's how I ended up
coming up with a story for it,
about a small-time criminal
who gets in way the hell
over her head.
And with "The Martian," it
was just a single person
was the main character.
You're rooting for
him to survive.
But I'm not-- I mean,
despite my success,
I am not a very good writer.
I'll say that.
I-- no one would accuse "The
Martian" of being literature,
right?
Mark Watney at the
end of the book
is the same as he was at
the beginning of the book.
He did not undergo any change.
He didn't grow as
a person at all.
You don't know anything
about his deeper motivations.
The only thing you know about
Mark Watney is he's smart
and he didn't want to die.
Well, that probably applies to
everyone in this room, right?
Like, you're all fairly smart
people, you work for Google,
and I'm guessing none of
you want to die, right?
And so there was
no depth at all.
And people liked
the story because it
was an entirely
plot-driven story
and it's all about
problem-solving.
But for "Artemis," I'm
like, I want to grow as a--
I want to become a
better writer than I am,
so I really want to make a
story that's character-driven.
I want to make a deep, complex
character who's flawed.
She's made bad
decisions in the past.
She makes bad decisions
during the course of the book.
She's a fundamentally
good person, though,
and she tries her best to do
good, while at the same time
being a bit of a screwup.
And that's what I was
shooting for with Jazz.
And I may have overshot
the mark a little bit,
because I know there's
some percentage of people--
I don't know.
What percentage of you
have read "Artemis" at all?
Yeah.
So it's like, yeah,
some people, not a lot.
And probably "The Martian"?
How about "The Martian"?
Yeah.
See, so "The Martian"
is much more popular.
But in "Artemis," some
people were actually
just alienated by Jazz,
the main character,
because she's such a screwup.
Like she tends to be
very self-destructive
and people are, like,
having a tough time
rooting for this person.
[LAUGHTER]
So anyway, that is the
extraordinarily roundabout
answer to your question
of the main differences.
I was really shooting for
a character-driven story
with "Artemis."
JASON GESSNER: Yeah, cool.
So sort of to that end,
in the acknowledgments
at the end of the
book, you have a lot
of people to thank
for sort of helping
you craft that character.
Could you talk a
little bit about that?
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
JASON GESSNER: And
how you approached
writing a female protagonist
in that situation?
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
So when I started--
like I said, I
designed the whole
city of Artemis first.
And then I started
coming up with stories
that might take place in it.
And I came up with a
story that was nothing
like "Artemis" is now.
I came up with a
completely different story,
a completely different
set of main characters.
Everything-- really almost
no overlap with the story
that the book became.
And I thought about
it, and Jazz Bashara, I
needed sort of an
underworld character.
I needed a person who's
like a lovable rogue.
And she was just going
to be in a few scenes.
And so I arbitrarily
decided, oh, Artemis
is intensely international.
It's like, if you're rich, if
you can afford to get there,
then you can get there.
Think of like
America in the 1830s.
Basically if you're from
Germany, if you can get here,
welcome aboard.
If you're from China, if you
can get here, hey, you're here.
You know, so it's the
same with Artemis,
and so I just kind of
picked random nationalities
for people.
And so I'm like, OK, my
lovable rogue, what's
a country I haven't used yet?
Saudi Arabia.
OK, good enough.
And what-- I'll
make her a woman,
just 'cause mental coin toss.
And so that's how
Jazz Bashara was born.
And I thought, oh, OK, she's--
in that walk-through, I just
kind of wrote an outline.
She was only in two
or three scenes.
She was there for
the main characters
to acquire some illegal
goods kind of thing.
Anyway, that plot,
that story sucked.
I thought about it and it
just wasn't working for me.
And I was just like,
ah, this isn't working.
This is not good.
But I think the setting
is really solid.
So I'm going to
ditch that story,
forget about all the characters,
whatever, they're all gone.
Come up with a completely
different story.
So I came up with
a second revision--
not even a revision, just a
completely different story.
And as needed, I plucked
the useful characters
that I'd already invented
and put them in there,
and Jazz was one of
the people that I did.
And here she was a
little more central,
but not the main
character by any means.
She was a little more prevalent.
I had to define her
a little deeper.
I'm like, oh, she grew up on
Artemis, and stuff like that.
And she is kind of a
lowlife, but she's also--
she's going to help the
protagonist at the end
because she loves her
city kind of thing.
But that was about it.
And that story also sucked,
and so I ditched that.
And I'm like, well,
Jazz is actually
a pretty interesting character.
So I'm like, well, what if I
wrote a story that's actually
centered on this
originally-intended-to-be
a secondary character?
And I'm like, well,
then they'd make
like a crime story, a
story like, you know,
a heist, a caper kind of thing.
And I'm like, I feel
like I could do that.
That could be interesting.
And so that's what "Artemis" is.
And so I found myself
in this situation
where I have a female
Saudi-descended protagonist.
You know, write what you know.
[LAUGHTER]
And so by that time, she
was so ingrained in my mind
as who she was, that if
I had tried to change her
into being something
I'm more familiar with,
like a white man, whatever,
my imagination would
have rebelled.
Would have gone,
now, now, no, no.
That's not who that is.
So I found myself in the
rather nerve-racking situation
of writing a female
lead character.
Now, the fact that she's
Saudi didn't really
matter, because although
she was born in Saudi Arabia
and lived there until
she was six years old,
she and her father moved
to the moon, to Artemis,
and she's been there ever since.
And so culturally
she is Artemisian.
Just like, again with the early
America metaphor, you know,
how the second
generation of kids,
they have a lot of
the morals and beliefs
from the old country,
but they're very much
a product of their environment
that they grew up in.
And so I didn't have
any problem with making
her a convincing Saudi
because she's not Saudi,
she's Artemisian.
And that's a culture I made
up, so I'm right by definition.
But being a woman, she's
a woman, however equal--
actually it's unequal, because
Jazz is abnormally intelligent.
She's a genius.
So-- but however equal
we are in intellect,
men and women are just
different psychologically
in a lot of ways.
And so I didn't
want to just write
a woman who seemed like a man.
And so I did the only thing
I could think of to do,
which is what I do with any
other scientific question,
is subject matter experts.
So after I wrote the
book, I handed it
to every woman I could
trust not to throw it up
on The Pirate Bay.
Just like-- every
woman in my circle
of trust, my girlfriend,
my mother, everybody
at the publisher
that was female,
I said, please read this.
I mean, read it and give me
whatever feedback you want,
but please also specifically
give me feedback
with an eye toward
convincing, or moments
that just rubbed you
the wrong way of like,
ooh, that didn't
seem like a woman.
That seems like a
man writing a woman.
JASON GESSNER: Sure.
ANDY WEIR: And I incorporated
that feedback and made changes.
But still in the end, you know,
there were complaints about it
in reviews at large, that she's
still a little too masculine.
Of course, I maintain she's a
woman who was born in the 2060s
and she grew up on the moon.
So she's not going to have
the exact same culture as you,
right?
And she is a little
bit of a tomboy,
but not in the sexy
male fantasy tomboy way,
but actually she's just gruff.
Yeah.
So it was a real challenge.
And in the
acknowledgments is where
I thanked most of
those women who'd
helped me refine her and
make her a little bit more
female without losing the feel.
JASON GESSNER: Sure.
ANDY WEIR: And one of them
is a lady that I know.
She actually works for the
American embassy in London.
And she gave me--
she is also a Muslim.
So she was able-- there is--
Jazz herself is not
a practicing Muslim,
but her father is a
very devout Muslim.
And so I wanted to make
sure that everything
jived with how Islam works.
And she checked all that
and I got all that right.
[LAUGHTER]
JASON GESSNER: You
mentioned that you threw out
a couple of earlier
versions of the story.
Were any of the characters
that survived in the published
version the previous
protagonists?
ANDY WEIR: No.
Let me see.
I'm running through
the protagonists.
So no, and no.
JASON GESSNER: OK.
ANDY WEIR: Like the main
characters of the first two
versions of the
story are not even--
don't even exist
in the main story.
JASON GESSNER: All right.
ANDY WEIR: However, my idea for
a sequel for "Artemis," which
is something I would
like to do someday,
revolves around
the-- a guy named
Rudy, who, for the four of you
who read it, is kind of the cop
there.
Artemis doesn't have
any laws, not really.
They're just a frontier town.
They have one kind
of security guy.
He's a former RCMP?
JASON GESSNER: Right.
ANDY WEIR: RCMP--
Mountie-- Royal Canadian M--
R-C-M-P, former member of the
RCMP, who retired and-- well,
he's not old, but he left
the forest to become, like,
the cop in Artemis.
He's very well respected.
He's very fair, very honest.
Honest to the point that--
yeah, and so he's actually
an antagonist for
Jazz in the story.
But I thought it'd be
really cool to write
a story in my next book about
him solving a murder there.
And I was going
to call it "Murder
on the Moon," which
unbelievably has never
been the title of anything.
I mean, I googled it.
I looked it up.
I said, like, surely there's
been a movie or a TV show
episode or something.
Just no.
And I'm like, I want
to write this book just
to lay claim to that title.
Like, "Murder on the Moon."
And I came up with a whole--
I'll walk through the murder
and how it takes place,
and there's scientific
elements, and how it picks up
from where "Artemis" left off.
And I pitched it
to the publisher,
and the publisher said, nah.
They didn't like it.
JASON GESSNER: OK.
ANDY WEIR: No free ride.
JASON GESSNER: [LAUGHS]
What's that?
You wrote a book that
sold 5 million copies?
Yeah, well, tell
me about this one.
JASON GESSNER: Just a
clean slate each time?
ANDY WEIR: Well,
yeah, pretty much.
Publishing-- you
know, book publishing
is very much a meritocracy.
And they want to--
they don't want to
just publish a dud.
They know that
people will buy kind
of whatever I write
for a while, just
because I wrote "The Martian."
But they would
rather it be a book
that's good and so that
people buy more of them,
so that everybody
makes more money.
And what I get--
the advantage I get
from being successful in the
past is that I get in the room,
is that I'm there.
And I get to talk to
the decision-makers
and say, here's my idea.
JASON GESSNER: Cool.
So one thing-- we talked
a little bit earlier about
how your background is
actually in software.
ANDY WEIR: Yes.
JASON GESSNER: Right?
In software--
ANDY WEIR: 25 years as
a software engineer,
before I wrote.
One clap?
One?
One micro-clap.
JASON GESSNER: [LAUGHS]
ANDY WEIR: I did--
this was the same
as like playing to the crowd
by naming the city you're in,
you know?
It's like, software engineer!
JASON GESSNER: It definitely
seemed like a softball.
ANDY WEIR: And this guy's like--
Yeah, it was a lob
and I'm just-- oh.
You people.
JASON GESSNER: So software is
a very collaborative endeavor,
right?
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
JASON GESSNER: You did
that for a quarter century.
Writing isn't--
ANDY WEIR: There is no need--
JASON GESSNER: Sorry.
ANDY WEIR: --to be putting it--
let's-- [LAUGHS]
JASON GESSNER:
No, no undertones.
You know--
ANDY WEIR: In my day--
JASON GESSNER: But writing a
novel is a much more solitary--
ANDY WEIR: It is.
JASON GESSNER: --adventure,
right, or endeavor.
With "The Martian,"
because you were
publishing it
chapter by chapter,
you had a community around it.
Could you talk a little
bit about that transition
from being in a, lack of a
better term, a team sport,
to a solo effort,
and how that was
different with "Artemis,"
which wasn't serialized
in the same way?
ANDY WEIR: Right.
So there's like actually two
completely different things
there.
And I'll answer them both.
The first one was,
writing "The Martian,"
I posted it a chapter
at a time to my website.
It was a labor of love.
It was a thing I
was doing for fun
while I was working full time
in the software industry.
For those of you who
don't know, I mean,
I started writing
software professionally
in the late 1980s.
[WHEEZE] It was
a different time.
Michael Jackson was still black.
Anyway-- taken straight
from "Hot Tub Time Machine,"
that joke.
But so I'd been in the software
industry for a long time.
The last 10 years of my career
were all in mobile development.
So I wrote "The
Martian" while I--
one thing that helped a lot
was having no social life
whatsoever.
So I had a lot of free
time in the evenings.
You know, no girlfriend,
no real friends.
I'd moved to Boston
and so I didn't really
know anybody there.
But that was a labor of love.
And for the past 10 years, I
had been maintaining a website
with the web comics and short
stories that I'd written,
and it had a mailing
list and had accumulated
about 3,000 regular readers.
Yay for me.
OK.
Well, when I started
posting "The Martian"
a chapter at a time, my
readers are hardcore dorks,
so I was targeting
them with the writing.
I was trying to make the writing
be extremely, meticulously,
scientifically accurate,
and showing the math,
because I know that's what that
sort of reader-- my people--
like to read.
And so they would
send me-- there
is nothing a nerd
loves more than finding
an error in a fiction, right?
And so they would
tell me anytime
I got anything wrong-- math,
chemistry, you name it.
And then it was cool,
since I was just
writing it and posting
it to my website,
I'd go back and correct it.
So I had this very, very
scientifically accurate thing.
They also suggested all
sorts of really stupid plot
ideas, which I ignored.
Engineers are not often very
good at plot generation,
but real good at math.
And so the end result was a
very, very well-fact-checked
story.
And with "Artemis," I
didn't have that option,
because "Artemis" was a
more traditional contract.
It was like, you know, Random
House gave me an advance.
I wrote the story just for them.
And then they
published it, you know.
And so I didn't have
3,000 highly intelligent
fact-checkers.
So the end result on that, the
only difference there was I
just had to be much, much, much
more careful in my research.
For "The Martian," I
would just quickly--
I mean, I've often said that my
main research tool is Google.
I mean, I know-- nowadays,
even when writing "Artemis,"
my main research
tool was Google.
Because, like, I know lots of
people, lots of scientists,
lots of famous people.
I can call up Neil deGrasse
Tyson and ask him questions.
But Google answers me faster.
[LAUGHTER]
You know?
JASON GESSNER: Take that, Neil.
ANDY WEIR: If I want to
know-- yeah, take that, Neil.
If I want to know
the finer details
of an Uphoff-Crouch lunar
cycler, I can Google it.
And there it is.
So I still end up doing that.
But I just had to be
a lot more thorough
with the fact-checking myself.
I had to be like,
OK, I can't just
trust the first few sites I see.
I have to double
and triple check.
I had to check all my
math multiple times
because I didn't have
all those fact-checkers.
And still a few mistakes did
get through, unfortunately.
But nothing moon-shattering.
JASON GESSNER: Sure.
ANDY WEIR: See what I did there?
I feel like that
was pretty good.
JASON GESSNER: [LAUGHS]
ANDY WEIR: Tough room.
OK.
So that was one part
of the question.
The other part was,
what was it like going
from being in a team environment
in software engineering
to being a solo writer?
And the answer is,
that was actually
the most difficult
transition for me.
I'm a pretty social guy.
So first off, I really enjoyed
being a software engineer.
It was a very rewarding job.
I liked it a lot.
I was in it for 25
years for a reason.
That was a career that
really worked for me.
JASON GESSNER: Sure.
ANDY WEIR: I'd worked my way
up to like, architect level.
I was good at it.
I was respected by my
peers and my bosses.
And, like, I just,
I really enjoyed it.
And I also really enjoyed
working on a team,
always being part
of a team, you know?
And I liked going
in in the morning,
grabbing a cup of coffee,
saying, hey, Steve,
how's your dog?
I heard he wasn't
feeling too good.
Oh, he's better.
Glad to hear it.
Hey, Joe, how'd that
baseball game with your boy
go last week?
You know, just being a
part of a social group.
The tight as-- I don't
know how many of you
are engineers
versus other tasks,
but for those of you who are
engineers, an engineering
team working on a single project
is a really tight-knit group.
And moving over to
writing, that was all gone.
You know, I didn't go into
an office everyday anymore.
I just went into my home office.
I didn't have people to
work with collaboratively
on a problem.
I was on my own.
I mean, I have people
that I work with.
I have my editor.
JASON GESSNER: Sure.
ANDY WEIR: I talk to
him-- my agent, actually.
And I talk a lot about plot
direction and stuff like that.
My fiancee and I--
my fiancee is also a
writer, so we bounce ideas
off of each other, just to be
each other's sounding boards
and stuff.
But it's not the same.
It's not a team of engineers
breaking up a big problem
into a bunch of little
problems and doling them out
and collaborating and stuff.
And I really, really miss that.
That was the hardest part.
And yeah.
And so one thing that
was pretty fun, though,
was last year I worked
on a TV show pitch,
called-- it was going
to be a show called
"Mission Control," which
was about Mission Control.
And all the main characters
were the flight controllers
at Mission Control in Houston.
And that was a writers' room
with a bunch of writers,
all working together on it.
And that gave me
that feel again.
I was like, this is cool.
This is back to being--
like being on an
engineering team.
There's a bunch of us all
working on a single thing.
Unfortunately, the show
didn't get picked up.
They did give us $10 million
to shoot a pilot, which we did.
And I thought it was good,
but there were 450 pilots
that season, and
ours was not one
of the ones they
decided to go with.
JASON GESSNER: So you have
a lot of technical detail
in the books.
Obviously that
was something that
was really important to
you, that sort of helped
spur that original audience.
Could you talk a little
bit about a couple
of the technical
challenges that you had
to investigate for "Artemis"?
ANDY WEIR: For "Artemis"?
OK.
Well, so I wanted
the building of the--
so the biggest challenge was
making everything make sense
economically.
That's-- I'm one of those
pedantic little shits,
when I look at something and
I'm like, where's the economics?
How's the economics
work out there?
Explain.
You know?
It's like-- and so, a lot
of times in science fiction
and stuff like that,
I'm always like,
I'm just questioning
the economics.
So for me, I'm like, OK,
how did Artemis get built?
They didn't send the whole
damn city to the moon.
That's too expensive.
They would make it out
of local materials.
And I found out the moon
has an assload of aluminum.
Like, all of the aluminum.
So much aluminum.
If you go to the moon
and you pick up a rock--
if you go to the
lunar highlands, which
is the bumpy parts, as opposed
to the smooth parts, right?
If you go to the bumpy
parts of the moon
and you pick up a rock,
there is an 85% chance
that you just picked up a
mineral called anorthite.
Anorthite is made of aluminum,
calcium, silicon, and oxygen.
It's very, very happy
being anorthite.
That's why it's been that way
for 4 and 1/2 billion years.
It's not a chemical
that wants to change.
However, it will change if you
shove enough energy through it.
And what you can do is,
you can yank it apart
into its component elements.
And that process, by the
way, is called smelting.
That's what smelting is.
They start with ore, and you
get refined metals out of it.
So refining anorthite,
I said, like, OK.
This is awesome
because it'll give us
a bunch of stuff we need.
So how do you refine anorthite?
How do you turn that
into something useful?
And you would think that
smelting technology would all
be hundreds of years old, right?
I mean, we've been refining
metals since forever ago.
Well, the primary process that
would be best for anorthite
is called the FFC
Cambridge process,
and it was invented in 1994.
So technology's
always moving forward.
And so I figured
out how that works.
And I'm like, OK, so
this will separate it
into its component elements.
And so you would get
aluminum, calcium, silicon,
and oxygen, right?
Notice I did this for
oxygen, because it's a gas.
And-- which is amazing, because
it means it gives you aluminum
to build your moon base,
and then oxygen to fill it.
I mean, like, the moon
is made of moon bases,
just some assembly required.
That also gives you calcium,
which is not that useful.
It actually is a
very good conductor,
if you wanted to make
wire, but it's also--
explodes when it touches
water, and there's
other problems with that.
But then there's
also silicon, so they
can make their own
glassware, which
is also really handy if
you don't mind reacting it
with some of the oxygen.
And boy, is there a lot
of oxygen. Just making
Artemis, the amount of aluminum
you need to make Artemis,
there's just so much oxygen you
can't breathe it fast enough.
I mean, you'd be-- they'd
be venting oxygen out
into the vacuum outside
just to get rid of it.
It's an absurd amount of
oxygen trapped in these rocks.
So oxygen, not a problem.
Also good to know, right?
And then I start going, like,
OK, so that's how they make it.
That's the cheapest
way to make it.
How much energy does it
take to smelt anorthite?
Oh, my god!
OK, so there are not
enough solar panels
to make that happen.
You would have to pave the
moon with solar panels.
You have to have
nuclear reactors.
There's no way to do this
without nuclear reactors.
So that started-- that,
I'm sure is when I ended up
on all sorts of watch lists, as
I'm looking up nuclear reactors
and finding out what US Navy
ships use because those are
the smallest, most lightest,
most efficient nuclear reactors
that exist.
And so I got some
information on that and said,
OK, Artemis is powered by
these two nuclear plants.
Then the problem becomes,
well, nuclear reactors
require a heat differential.
How do you get rid of
the heat in a world
that doesn't have any water--
or air, for that matter?
And so there is these
dadadadadadadah.
It just keeps going.
But that was really fun.
The lame part is where
I have to come up
with characters in a story.
[LAUGHTER]
Now, what I would have
liked to have done
is just released a technical
schematic of Artemis
and called it a day.
But people probably
wouldn't buy that.
JASON GESSNER: Yeah.
ANDY WEIR: Not as much.
JASON GESSNER: Those
details come across--
ANDY WEIR: One guy
would, back there.
He's like, I would.
JASON GESSNER: Those details
come across in the book,
but they're not
overbearing, either.
ANDY WEIR: Yeah,
that's the hard part.
Oh boy, is that hard,
because I do so much back--
I do so much work to
make everything work out,
to make all the
science, all the math,
everything has to work
for me to be happy.
And then it ends up being
like a sentence in the book.
Because it's really
hard to resist the urge.
It's like, look, it took me
a long time to work this out.
It should take you a
long time to read it.
But no.
You have to-- you can do
all the math and stuff,
but you have to
just keep on task.
JASON GESSNER: One of my
favorite details related
to the power was,
I think there's
a sentence where they're
like, well, what happens
if the reactors explode?
Then they're like, ah, put
a bunch of dirt in the way.
ANDY WEIR: Yep.
JASON GESSNER: So
there's a giant berm.
ANDY WEIR: Yep.
That's it.
That's their safety.
Because there's-- Artemis
is a bunch of, like--
so Artemis' hulls are made of
6 centimeters of aluminum--
metric guy will appreciate this.
6 centimeters of
aluminum, a meter
of crushed lunar rock--
just basically sand,
not processed at all.
Just straight-up
crushed lunar rock.
And then another 6
centimeters of aluminum.
And the interstitial
space is divided up
into triangles like
a geodesic dome.
And the reason for that is,
I think, four-fold or so.
First off, it provides
thermal insulation.
So the temperature
inside Artemis
doesn't really change
based on whether or not
it's day or night outside.
I figured out the
temperature gradient
to change 1 degree across
that would take like a century
or something like that.
It's amazing how much the
temperature, how much heat
does not want to move
through ground-up rock.
Number two is
radiation protection.
That'll protect against
background radiation
and solar radiation
to bring it down
to kind of similar to
the levels of radiation
on the surface of Earth.
Number three is
physical protection
from micro-meteorites
and whatnot.
But much more importantly,
physical protection
from the idiots who live inside.
Because if you make
a city on the moon,
the greatest danger
to the whole integrity
are the people inside.
Some guy pointing a
rivet gun the wrong way.
Oops, you know.
The fourth thing it does
is it helps to radiate out
the excess heat, because all the
energy that you use ultimately
becomes heat.
Either it's a light
bulb that became heat,
or it's mechanical
motion that became
friction that became heat.
Every jewel of energy that
goes in there becomes heat.
And so there are heat
regulators just pointed out.
So Artemis is a compound,
if you think about it.
Like you could shoot RPGs at it
and still not breach the hull.
And those two hulls
are each independently
capable of keeping
in an atmosphere.
So a hull breach just means you
calmly get everybody else out
to other parts of the city,
seal off that section,
and like that.
So the nuclear reactors
are about a kilometer away.
And they said, like, what
if there's a meltdown?
Well, who gives a shit?
There is no water
table to contaminate.
There's no life to hurt.
There's-- we're already very,
very radiation-shielded.
So all we have to do is protect
against an actual physical
explosion.
And they did that
by making a hill.
So that's it.
That's all they did.
And these reactors
are just like,
not a lot of
shielding, but oh no.
What are you going to--
oh, the ecology of the moon?
No.
Nobody gives a shit.
JASON GESSNER: Because your work
is very fact-based and it is
very rigid in that way--
but I'm curious, like, what
are your thoughts on sci-fi
as inspiration, both as you were
growing up and its role now?
Like, how has it changed?
ANDY WEIR: Well, I think every--
basically every scientific idea
starts off as science fiction.
It's just that the guy who came
up with it doesn't realize it.
Anytime you sit there and go,
what if we use this to do that?
That's science fiction.
You just did that in your mind.
So eventually it
becomes science fact.
It's just some people
then go off the deep end,
like me, and write an
entire book about the idea
instead of actually doing
something useful for society,
like working on the problem.
But so I think that
science fiction is just
another way to say
speculation about the future.
In terms of its
role, I try not to--
I don't feel like I'm a
part of anything bigger.
I am just-- my
objective when I'm
writing a book is
to make something
that people enjoy reading.
And the only thing
I want you to think
when you put the book
away is, that was cool.
And that's it.
I'm not trying to change
your mind on anything.
I have no message.
I have no moral.
There is no politics.
There's no-- I'm not saying
we should work on this,
or do that, or anything.
I'm just saying,
hey, neat story idea.
And I want you to say,
hey, that was neat.
That's it.
So I don't really
think of entertai--
I feel like
entertainment in general,
the entertainment
industry is kind of,
to be blunt, up its own ass.
It just-- there's
a lot of people
just really believe
that they are
the social conscience
of the world
and it's their job to guide.
I don't buy into that.
I'm just about making
people have fun.
JASON GESSNER: So
since you get sort
of pulled into that
anyway, though,
does that cause a lot
of tension for you?
Or you're just like,
no, that's not my bag.
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
For the most part, people
accept it when I say, nope.
You know.
It's like, well, what about
the political meaning?
There is no political meaning.
Well, what about the-- nope.
[LAUGHS] And there is
kind of an argument,
especially in the science
fiction writing community,
about whether or
not science fiction
has a responsibility to be
some sort of standard-bearer
for morality or
progressiveness, or whatever.
And I guess on that, I
do say, well, yeah, I
have a strong opinion on that.
No.
I don't think it does.
I think it's just my job is
entertain, and nothing more.
Yeah.
JASON GESSNER: What were
some of the main inspirations
to you when you
were younger, then?
ANDY WEIR: Well,
I grew up reading
my dad's science fiction
collection, which
is interesting.
So my dad--
I'm Gen X, my dad's
a baby boomer.
So I grew up one generation off.
So the science
fiction that was being
written when I was a
teenager, I didn't read that.
I read Heinlein, and
Arthur Clarke, and Asimov,
and stuff like that.
And so I read my
dad's collection,
so the pages are
kind of yellowed.
And at the halfway
point, there's
an ad for Kent Cigarettes,
and stuff like that.
You know, black people are
called "colored" in the books.
I mean, it's just like
these old, old books.
But it was just that's
the science fiction
that I grew up with.
And what's interesting
is that was an era--
those guys wrote science fiction
that was very optimistic.
Like there was an optimism to
sci-fi that was present then,
where it's like, oh,
I'm going to tell you
a story about this guy who
has an adventure in this world
where the whole solar system is
like, you know, is colonized.
And all these problems,
all these health problems
have been solved.
There's no such thing
as cancer anymore.
But these guys have a problem
with these space pirates.
Yeah, yeah, it's awesome.
And now, science fiction
seems to have been taken over
by bleak dystopian miseryscapes
with fascist governments,
and the only people
who can save us all
are a group of teenagers
doing something weird.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm like, when did science
fiction become so negative?
Because I honestly
believe that--
I mean, I'm an optimistic guy.
I write optimistic stories.
I honestly believe that
humanity and Earth and science
and everything just gets
better and better and better.
And if you don't believe me,
I put the thought experiment
to you--
would you rather live now
or a hundred years ago?
You want to live a
hundred years ago, 1918?
Enjoy your Spanish flu.
Do you like tuberculosis?
Hey.
Hey, what ethnicity are you?
Because you might not be able
to go into that restaurant,
you know.
And so it's like we just keep
getting better and better.
Science, socially, everything.
Just better and
better over time.
And so this notion
that we're somehow
going to stop that upward trend
we've had for the past 5,000
years and go straight to
hell, I don't buy into that.
And so I just wish there was
a little more positive science
fiction.
And I think the best example
of positive science fiction
out there is still "Star Trek."
Like, "Star Trek" is--
I mean, the problems
that the Enterprise
have notwithstanding,
"Star Trek"
is a pretty bright future.
It would be awesome to live
on Earth in the "Star Trek"
universe.
I mean, there's no
problems at all.
There's no poverty.
There's no hunger.
There's no disease.
It's just like
everybody's got everything
they need taken care of.
You're only endangered
if you decide
to go way out to the
fringes of Federation space
and start poking around, and--
JASON GESSNER: Sure.
Does it bug you that they
don't talk about the economics
in "Star Trek"?
ANDY WEIR: Yes, it does.
How the fuck does the
economics work in that?
[LAUGHTER]
In "Star Trek IV,"
Kirk's like, oh, we
don't have money in the future.
I'm like, how do
you conduct trade?
You just show up to the baker
with a bunch of chickens?
Here you go.
I don't get it.
But you know, OK.
JASON GESSNER: Yeah, there is
a hopefulness in "Star Trek."
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
And if there's one thing
that drives me crazy,
is just kind of technophobia.
Like the idea of any
technology is automatically bad
and will make you miserable.
Also known as the entirety
of "Black Mirror," right?
That show is just like, here's
how technology is always,
always 100% bad.
And I don't buy that.
Yeah, technology is bad.
As soon as we invented the
car, we invented the car crash.
But we also invented
the ambulance, you know?
We do more good than harm with
technology, almost always.
JASON GESSNER: Well, cool.
So those are all
of my questions.
First off, thank you very much.
Why don't we open it up--
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: You mentioned that you
had a bunch of female readers
read your book and
give you feedback.
Do you have any
examples of things
that you got wrong that
they told you to fix?
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
Sure.
Like, at one point--
this one is
literally every woman
who read it flagged this one.
At one point, she was having
an argument with her dad.
And she's 26, OK?
And she was having an
argument with her dad
and she's like, oh, fuck you.
And everyone's like,
we get mad at our dads.
We almost never
say, like, fuck you.
[LAUGHTER]
You know, we'll say other stuff.
You know, women,
when they're having
an argument with
their fathers, it
can get really emotional and
angry and stuff like that.
But just straight-up fuck you?
Mm, very rare.
So they all flagged that.
So I changed that.
And also just some
turns of phrase.
Just the way certain
things that she
said that are things that,
like, a lot of the ladies
who read it said, like, eh.
That's-- I mean, that's
an expression you hear all
the time and it's
not even offensive,
but it's just a thing that guys
usually say and women usually
don't.
So like small things like that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So thank you so much for coming.
ANDY WEIR: Thanks for having me.
AUDIENCE: I actually
just finished my--
a fiction novel, my first one.
And I--
ANDY WEIR: Congratulations.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDY WEIR: That's the
hardest part, is--
AUDIENCE: Well, I
actually would disagree.
ANDY WEIR: OK.
AUDIENCE: I'd say the hardest
part so far has been--
I'm just now in the process
of trying to get an agent.
ANDY WEIR: That is hard.
AUDIENCE: That is hard.
And I'd love to get
your perspective
on after you published in--
you know, it's in series.
So that's technically
self-publishing.
Can you speak about that?
And then can you speak about
getting an agent after?
And what you'd recommend.
And I just would
love to be a sponge
and soak up everything you say.
ANDY WEIR: Sure.
Well, I definitely
recommend first trying
to get an agent through
the normal means.
They all have websites.
They all have
submission standards.
They actually-- you may
feel like they're not
reading what you send them,
but they are, I assure you.
That's their whole job.
And so they're reading
them and evaluating them.
A lot of them, when you get
your many rejection notices,
a lot of them will tell
you what they didn't
like, which is very helpful.
Earlier in my career, if it
makes you feel any better--
"The Martian" is actually
the third book that I wrote.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANDY WEIR: The
first book I wrote
was called "The Observer."
I wrote that when
I was in college.
Thank god I wrote it before
the era of the internet,
so it's not out there.
None of you will ever see it.
It's awful.
It's oh-ful, OK?
And then the second
book that I ever wrote
was called "Theft
of Pride," which--
so basically, when I was
working for America Online
back in 1999, I got laid off
when they merged with Netscape.
Yes.
It was a different time.
The Macarena was popular.
So I got laid off and
I had a bunch of money
from stock options.
And so I said, I'm going to
be a professional writer.
Yay, me.
And so I spent
three years writing
this book, "Theft
of Pride," and then
trying to get it published.
And that is when I had
my standard tale of woe
that every author has, which
is rejection, rejection,
rejection, rejection.
And then I eventually went back
into the software industry.
But it wasn't a sad,
Charlie-Brown-music,
hang-your-head thing,
because I loved software.
I just-- I said, I
have an opportunity
to pursue this dream.
I did.
It didn't work out.
OK, back to the career that
I already enjoyed anyway.
But so I went through it
too, and I know how it feels.
But what's awesome
now is that there
is no longer an old-boy network
between you and the readers.
If you can't get through
on the tradition--
on the old-school approach
of finding an agent,
getting a publisher,
stuff like that,
then go ahead and try
to publish it directly.
Amazon is easy.
It's, you post it up there,
they hang onto it for 24 hours
to make sure it's not
goat porn or something.
And then-- they just want
to categorize it correctly
if it is, you know.
[LAUGHTER]
And then--
AUDIENCE: One of those comps.
ANDY WEIR: --they
put it up there--
they put it up there for sale.
You can charge--
I recommend that if you go
the self-publishing route,
since you're trying
to accumulate readers
at this point,
don't go for money.
Go for readership.
So set the price to the absolute
minimum, which is $0.99,
or it was when I
published "The Martian,"
and see if you can get
some traction that way.
But it's nice because
it costs you zero.
It costs you nothing.
And that is a big change
from the way publishing was
up until this modern
era, is that--
it used to be if you
really believed in a book
and no one would publish it,
you would vanity press it.
And then you're putting
thousands, tens of thousands
of your own dollars into it.
You no longer have to do that.
But definitely try the
traditional route first,
because it can't be overstated
how useful a publisher is,
in terms of marketing
and publicity.
They can get so many more
people to hear about your work
than you can on your own,
that it's just no comparison.
And the last thing
I would say is,
don't go directly
to a publisher.
Get an agent.
If you can't find an agent,
then consider self-publishing.
But going directly
to a publisher, that
will end up in a
slush pile in a room,
in a back room
that is forgotten,
you know, next to the
Ark of the Covenant.
So that's my advice.
AUDIENCE: Can I ask
one more question?
ANDY WEIR: No one seems
to be fighting you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Can you speak a little bit
about your relationship
with your editor and how--
do you even have one
with "The Martian"?
And then, how is
that transformed,
and how influential has
that been in your work
with "Artemis"?
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
So for "The Martian,"
the entire book
was done before Random
House got involved.
But then, I mean,
I had an editor
and he went through and sent
me a big pile of red ink
with some paper in between it.
And so I went through the
process of editing it.
It wasn't that bad.
For "Artemis" it
was very different
because I would send
him a chapter at a time.
I didn't have to do that.
He was happy to just say, send
it to me when you're done.
But I was sending
it to him a chapter
at a time and stuff like that.
And I have a great
relationship with my editor.
His name is Julian Pavia.
He works for Random
House in New York City.
And I think he really works
hard to make good stories.
He doesn't have a focus on
demographics or market shares,
or anything like that.
He doesn't care
about any of that.
He's just like, how do we
make this a good story?
And he'll point out problems.
And damn it, every time he
points something out, I'm like,
you're right.
And I just like--
I've never had him
point out something
that I really disagreed with.
And I'm like, ooh, fucker.
But we don't butt
heads very often.
My only complaint about
him is that sometimes it
just seems like
I just can't find
anything that makes him happy.
Sometimes it feels that way.
But yeah, it's an
interesting relationship.
But this is where being a
software engineer for so long
comes into play.
I mean, I'm used to
collaborative work.
I'm used to having to re--
I'm used to making a product
and then presenting it
to a higher-up, who
then wants to make
a bunch of arbitrary changes.
And then you go [INAUDIBLE]
and you go make them.
AUDIENCE: Right.
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDY WEIR: Sure thing.
Good luck.
AUDIENCE: So between
the two books,
it seemed to me like there
was quite a bit of difference
in the tone.
I thought "The Martian" had a
lot of levity, a lot of humor
in it.
Seems like maybe that's a
little bit of your personality,
as we've been listening to you.
ANDY WEIR: Mark is me.
I admit it.
Well, Mark is the idealized me.
He's all the parts of
my personality I like,
and none of the parts
of me that I don't like.
He's what I wish I could be.
And pretty much
every main character
is someone the
author wants to be,
or someone the author
wants to screw.
And if you don't believe
me, pick any book
and think it through.
[LAUGHTER]
By the way, I want to be Mark.
Just FYI.
AUDIENCE: All right,
so now I think
my question is really weird.
[LAUGHTER]
So "Artemis," I
think has kind of a--
ANDY WEIR: Darker.
AUDIENCE: --like a darker tone.
And I wondered if, like,
was that deliberate?
Something you set out to do?
Did that evolve naturally?
ANDY WEIR: It evolved
naturally and the reason
is because, like I was saying
before, I really wanted--
my main goal for myself
on writing "Artemis"
was to make deeper,
more complex characters.
To make characters
who are more flawed
and have deep
psychological things
that the reader understands,
and then undergoes
change and growth.
And so while Mark
is the idealized me,
Jazz is really more
like the real me.
So a lot of the
problems that Jazz has,
and a lot of her behavior, is
stuff that I do or have done.
And like her strained
relationship with her father.
That's straight out of my life.
The fact that she's--
a recurring theme in the book
is that she's really, really,
really intelligent, but
doesn't apply it nearly enough.
And people are
always saying, you
could be doing so much more.
And she's like, fuck off.
You know.
And that's-- she's kind
of the darker side of me.
So you remember that
episode of "Star Trek" where
Captain Kirk gets
split into his good guy
half and his evil half?
And he's wandering around,
there are two Kirks on the ship,
and stuff like that?
That's kind of like Mark
Watney and Jazz Bashara for me.
AUDIENCE: So in the
movie "The Martian,"
it seemed like the humor was
maybe exaggerated more than
what it came across in
the book and I was--
ANDY WEIR: Hm.
AUDIENCE: At least to me.
So you seem like you're
disagreeing with that.
I was going to ask you
how you felt about that.
But maybe you disagree
with my analysis.
ANDY WEIR: I guess I disagree,
but there is no wrong answer
in critical analysis.
I mean, except yours.
That was wrong.
But--
[LAUGHTER]
--no, I disagree.
I think the humor came
across pretty well.
That having been said, you
know, film and literature
are two very, very different
media for conveying stories.
You have to do things
differently in a film.
I was very happy with how
the movie came across,
so I'm certainly-- certainly
got no complaints about that
whatsoever.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDY WEIR: Mhm.
AUDIENCE: So you're a pretty
technical person, right?
So I'm just wondering, did you
hack the writing process a lot?
Or did your room look
like something from--
ANDY WEIR: Serial
killer's basement?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, exactly.
Like you're getting
the Unabomber
with all the red thread
pointing everywhere.
Or is it like you have
a Google Doc, right?
ANDY WEIR: Not a Google
Doc, because I didn't
want to share it with anybody.
AUDIENCE: OK.
ANDY WEIR: But I do have a
directory full of spreadsheets.
So mostly I have
like Excel docs.
Just tons and tons of math, all
that stuff is done like that.
But yes, I also
have a whiteboard--
a magnetic whiteboard
with things
that I'll print out, like
a little map of Artemis
and stuff like that.
AUDIENCE: Was that
exaggerated for "Artemis"
versus "The Martian," where you
add like blog-style writing?
ANDY WEIR: Well, yeah, "Artemis"
was much more serial killer-y.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDY WEIR: A lot
of "Artemis" has
to do with distances
and locations.
And it's like, oh god, she's--
OK, she's here.
She needs to get there.
How long does that take?
And that becomes plot-critical.
And so the map really
mattered a lot.
In "The Martian," it was really
just all about spreadsheets.
And I wrote some
software of my own
for calculating the orbital
trajectories that people took.
AUDIENCE: That's awesome.
One quick question
in follow-up, too,
is, do you have Matt
Damon's phone number?
ANDY WEIR: I don't
have his phone number.
I did meet him many times during
the publicity and marketing
for the film.
He's very-- that's
usually what people ask.
What's Matt Damon like?
Well, I'll tell you.
He's very nice.
He's as polite to the waiter
as he is to the director.
He's just a generally
nice person,
and he's also very introverted.
He is.
He's really quiet.
And you can tell, at these
marketing events, none of us
are at our best because
we've all traveled
and we're all-- none of us
really want to be there.
You know, we're all just, OK,
yeah, we're here to do this.
And you can tell he would--
he's very nice to everybody.
He's very polite.
And he very much
would rather be just
at home with his wife
and kids, relaxing.
AUDIENCE: First off, a TV
show about Mission Control
sounds really cool.
I would kill to watch that.
ANDY WEIR: Thanks!
I mean, you don't-- you
shouldn't really kill people
for it, but I mean--
AUDIENCE: So my
question is just,
how much time did
you spend developing
the science and the
characters of "Artemis"
before you actually sat down
and started writing chapters?
ANDY WEIR: That's an interesting
question because, I mean,
I spent a good couple of months
working on those dead-end plot
line ideas before I got there.
Now, the science I blew through
in like a few weeks of just--
that stuff is so fun to me.
I just-- I'll just stay up
late working on that crap.
But the characters and stuff,
that was time-consuming.
Also at the same time, I was
working on a different book.
Between "The "Martian
and "Artemis,"
I was working on a
book called "Zhek."
And that was about
aliens invading Earth.
And it was like a complete
departure from the hard sci-fi
that I was used to.
And I got about
70,000 words into it--
for reference, "The "Martian
is 100,000 words, 105,000.
So I got about 70,000
words into "Zhek"
over the course of a year.
And I realized one day, I'm
like, oh dear, this sucks.
And I told my
editor, I'm like, I'm
concerned that "Zhek" sucks.
Would it be OK if I wrote
a completely different book
and you added a
year to my deadline?
And he said, sure, go ahead.
Because he'd been reading
the chapters and he
also knew that "Zhek" sucked.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
--he was actually very
comfortable with that.
But while I was bungling
around trying to fix "Zhek"--
and I did.
I spent a lot of time trying
to make it work as a story--
I was also cheating on it
by going over and working
on "Artemis."
So it's hard for me to
give a quantitative answer
because I kind of split my time.
AUDIENCE: So the question
I had was about the film
adaptation and what--
you've probably been
asked this before,
but what are your just
general thoughts on that?
And also, I'm curious
kind of how they reach out
to you on that,
and wanting to turn
the book into a movie,
and kind of the process
of that happening.
ANDY WEIR: They send a
jewel-encrusted helicopter.
No.
So what happened was, while we
were negotiating the book deal
with Random House, Fox wanted
the film rights, right then.
Like they came-- like it was
still just a self-published
book on Amazon when Fox--
for those of you who
don't understand,
the way movie options
work, is what they're doing
is they're paying you
a small amount of money
to have the exclusive ability
to buy the film rights from you.
So it's not like you're
just rolling in money
and they're going
to make a movie.
It's like, we may or may
not want to make a movie out
of this, but we're going
to secure it by giving you
a small amount of money.
You pre-negotiate the entire
contract, the whole purchase
contract in advance.
And we're going to give
you a small amount of money
to be the only people who can
buy the rights for the next,
like, 18 months.
It expires.
And we can buy the
rights at any time
just by activating this
contract and then giving you
the big pile of money.
So when they came
for the film option,
it wasn't that
big of a surprise.
Movie studios buy film option--
they'll throw those out
and they're like
breath mints to them.
I mean, it's a lot of money
to me, but to them it's like,
pfft, here.
Go buy yourself
something pretty.
You know.
But they bought film rights.
And so those two deals were
going on at the same time.
And the book deal
and the film deal
came together four days apart.
And that was a-- you know,
and I was, by the way,
still working as an engineer.
So I'm in my
cubicle fixing bugs,
then running off to
a conference room,
take a call about my
movie deal, then back
to my cubicle to fix bugs.
It was a surreal time.
But anyway, as the
movie progressed--
there's never a moment
when you pop the champagne.
It's just bit by bit.
They're like, oh, we got a guy.
We've got a potential
screenwriter.
So we're going
to-- you know, he's
going to start working on that.
Oh, OK.
We think we may--
we've got a pretty
good screenplay.
The studio is like,
well, we're not--
it's so heavily dependent
on one character
that we're not going to
make it at all unless you
can get a big name
to play that one guy.
And it's like, OK, we pitched
it to Robert Downey Jr.
and he said no.
And then, so then
they're, we're going
to pitch it to Matt Damon
next, see what he says.
Matt Damon said yes.
I was like, what?
[LAUGHTER]
And then they had Drew
Goddard lined up to direct,
but then he left to go work
on Sony's next "Marvel" movie.
And so then they're
like, OK, well,
we've got Matt Damon interested,
but we need a director.
And then Ridley Scott said yes.
And I said, what?
And so then the studio started
to-- and it starts to snowball,
but there's never a moment.
And they're like, OK, well,
they're talking about,
they're doing some
concept sketches.
OK, well, Ridley's
meeting with that.
OK, well, now
Jessica Chastain is
interested in playing
Commander Lewis
and we're starting to get a
cast together, but none of this
means that we're actually
going to make the movie.
And then, OK, well,
eventually it's
like, well, we've leased some
studio space in Budapest.
It's like, OK, well,
we're making sets now.
I'm like, well,
that's good, isn't it?
Yeah, but it doesn't
always, eh, you know--
[LAUGHTER]
And then eventually they
shot the first scene.
And that's when you kind
of pop the champagne.
Because once they
shoot the first scene,
they're on the hook to pay
all the actors all the money.
And that's the expensive
part, is the salaries
that the actors make.
So once they shoot that
first scene, then it--
even if they wanted to stop,
the cheaper thing to do
is just power through and make
the movie to offset the costs.
And that's when they gave me the
big pile of money, too, which
was awesome.
I recommend it.
And--
[LAUGHTER]
--another thing that I get
asked a lot is, like, OK,
how were you involved in the
process of making the movie?
My job was to cash the check.
That's it.
Like, once you yield the--
once you sell the film rights,
they don't have to
talk to you at all.
They chose to include me,
though, which was pretty cool.
When Drew was writing
the screenplay,
he was on the phone
with me every day,
usually with
technical questions,
although sometimes
the story questions.
Ridley would also--
it took me a long time
to get used to the fact, by the
way, that in Hollywood everyone
calls each other by first names.
And so I'm like, man,
everybody's such a douche.
They're talking about these
incredibly famous people,
and they're like,
oh, Matt, oh, Ridley.
And then after like two
weeks in that environment,
you're doing it too.
So pardon me if I
sound like a douche,
but this is just how they do it.
So Ridley Scott
would be calling me,
sending questions
through intermediaries
with technical stuff.
But for the most part,
they certainly didn't--
I had no authority whatsoever.
And I had no say over anything.
But I'm very happy
with how it turned out.
As excited spectator
on the sidelines.
Yay!
Go team!
JASON GESSNER: Well, cool.
So everybody, let's give a big
round of applause for Andy.
[APPLAUSE]